Realmente es un honor es un honor estar aquí, y como dijo Chris,
van más de veinte años desde que comencé a trabajar en África.
Mi primera introducción fue en el aeropuerto de Abiyán una calurosa mañana en la Costa de Marfil.
Acababa de dejar Wall Street, cortarme el cabello para parecerme a Margaret Mead,
regalado casi todas mis posesiones
y llegado con todo lo esencial--
algunas poesías, un poco de ropa y, por supuesto, una guitarra--
porque iba a salvar el mundo
y pensaba que sólo empezaría con el continente africano.
Pero literalmente dentro de días de haber llegado, se me hizo entender por un grupo de mujeres de África Occidental,
en términos nada inciertos, que los africanos no querían a nadie que los salvara,
muchas gracias, y menos que a nadie a mí.
Yo era muy jóven, soltera, no tenía hijos,
no conocía a África realmente y, además, mi francés era penoso.
Y por lo tanto, fue un tiempo increíblemente doloroso en mi vida
y sin embargo realmente me empezó a dar la humildad necesaria para comenzar a escuchar.
Creo que el fracaso también puede ser una fuerza increíble de motivación,
así que me mudé a Kenya y trabajé en Uganda
y conocí a un grupo de mujeres de Ruanda quienes me pidieron, en 1986,
que me mudara a Kigali y les ayudara a establecer la primera institución de microfinanzas en el país.
Y lo hice, y terminamos llamándola Duterimbere,
que significa "avanzar con entusiasmo." Y mientras hacíamos eso,
me dí cuenta de que no habían muchos negocios que fueran viables
y establecidos por mujeres, y que tal vez también debería intentar manejar un negocio.
Así que comencé a buscar y me enteré de una repostería
que manejaban 20 prostitutas.
Y, un poco intrigada, fui a conocer a este grupo,
y lo que encontré fue a 20 madres solteras que intentaban sobrevivir.
Y realmente fue ese el principio de mi entender el poder que tiene el lenguaje
y cómo lo que llamamos gente tan a menudo nos distancia de ellos
y los hace pequeños.
También me enteré que la repostería no era nada como un negocio,
de hecho, era una obra de caridad clásica, manejada por una persona bien-intencionada
que esencialmente gastaba 600 dólares al mes
para mantener empleadas a estas 20 mujeres haciendo artesanías y reposterías
y viviendo de 50 centavos diarios, aún en pobreza.
Así que hice un trato con las mujeres. Les dije, "Miren, nos deshacemos del lado caritativo
y corremos esto cómo un negocio y las ayudo."
Consintieron un poco nerviosas, yo empecé un poco nerviosa, y por supuesto,
las cosas siempre son más difíciles de lo que uno se imagina.
Primero que todo, pensé, bueno, nos hace falta un equipo de ventas
y está claro que aquí no somos el Los Magníficos (Brigada A)
así que -- hice todo un entrenamiento
y el epítome fue cuando literalmente marché hasta la calle
de Nyamirambo, que es el barrio popular de Kigali, con un cubo
y les vendí todas las donitas a la gente
y volví y dije, "Ven?"
Y las mujeres dijeron, "Sabes, Jacqueline, quién en Nyamirambo no va a comprarle
donas en un cubo color naranja a una mujer alta y americana?" Y, pues--
(Risa) Es un buen punto.
Así que usé el método totálmente americano,
con competencias, en equipo e individuales. Fracaso total,
pero al pasar el tiempo las mujeres aprendieron a vender a su manera.
Y comenzaron a escuchar al mercado
y volvieron con la idea de hacer virutas de mandioca y guineo
y pan de sorgo, y antes de darnos cuenta,
teníamos acorralado al mercado de Kigali
y las mujeres se estaban ganando entre tres y cuatro veces más que el promedio nacional.
Y con esa ola de confianza pensé, bueno, ya es hora de crear una repostería de verdad,
así que vamos a pintarla. Y las mujeres dijeron, "Es muy buena idea."
Y yo dije,"Pues, de qué color la quieren pintar?" Y ellas dijeron,
"Pues, escoge tú." Y yo dije, "No, no, yo estoy aprendiendo a escuchar --
ustedes escojan. Es su repostería, su calle, su país, no los míos."
Pero se negaban a darme una respuesta.
Así pasaron una, dos, tres semanas
y por fin dije, "Pues, que tal azul?"
Y ellas dijeron, "Azul, azul, nos encanta el azul. Vamos a pintarla de azul."
Asi que, fui a la tienda, traje a Gaudence, la más obstinada de todas,
y compramos toda esta pintura y tela para hacer cortinas,
y el día que ibamos a pintar nos juntamos todos en Nyamarimbo
y la idea original era que pintaríamos de blanco con el borde azul,
como una repostería francesa. Pero claramente eso no era tan satisfactorio como
pintar una pared entera de color azul como el cielo mañanero.
Así que azul, azul, todo se convirtió en azul;
las paredes estaban azules, las ventanas estaban azules,
la acera en frente estaba pintada de azul.
Y Aretha Franklin estaba gritando "R.E.S.P.E.T.O.,"
las caderas de las mujeres se movían con la música
y los niñitos trataban de quitarles las brochas, pero el día era de ellas.
Y al final de todo, nos paramos al otro lado de la calle
y miramos lo que habíamos hecho, y dije "Es una belleza,"
y las mujeres dijeron, "De veras que sí."
Y yo dije, "Y me parece que es el color perfecto,"
y todas asintieron con la cabeza, menos Gaudence,
y yo dije, "¿Qué?"
Y ella dijo, "Nada," y yo volví a preguntar "¿Qué?"
Y ella dijo, "Bueno, está muy bonita, pero sabes que nuestro color, realmente, es el verde." Y --
(Risa).
Y aprendí entonces que escuchar no es sólo tener paciencia,
sino también que cuando has vivido de caridad y dependiente de otros toda tu vida,
es muy difícil decir lo que piensas.
Y, casi siempre es porque la gente nunca te pregunta
y cuando lo hacen, no crees que realmente quieran la verdad.
Y entonces aprendí que escuchar no es sólo esperar,
sino que también es aprender cómo hacer preguntas mejor.
Y entonces, viví en Kigali por alrededor de dos años, haciendo todas estas cosas,
y fue un tiempo extraordinario en mi vida.
Y me enseño tres lecciones
que creo ser tan importantes para nosotros hoy,
y ciertamente en mi área de trabajo.
La primera es que la dignidad es más importante para el espíritu humano que la fortuna.
Como dijo Elene, cuando las personas aumentan su ingreso, también aumentan sus opciones,
y eso es fundamental para la dignidad.
Pero como seres humanos también queremos vernos,
y queremos ser escuchados por los demás, y nunca debemos olvidar eso.
La segunda es que la caridad y la ayuda tradicional
nunca van a resolver los problemas de la pobreza.
Creo que Andrew cubrió esto bastante bien, así que voy a cuntinuar al tercer punto
que es que los mercados sólos tampoco
van a resolver los problemas de la pobreza.
Sí, manejamos esto como un negocio
pero alguien tenía que poner el apoyo filantrópico
que llevó el entrenamiento, el apoyo gerencial, el consejo estratégico
y tal vez más importante que todo lo demás,
el acceso a contactos, redes y mercados nuevos.
Y así, al nivel micro, hay un papel verdadero para esta combinación
de inversión y filantropía.
Y al nivel macro, algunos de los que han hablado han inferido que
hasta la salud debe de privatizarse.
Pero, habiendo tenido un padre con enfermedades del corazón,
y dándome cuenta que lo que mi familia podía pagar
no es lo que él debio haber recibido,
y habiendo tenido un buen amigo que intercedió para ayudarnos,
de veras creo que todas las personas merecen acceso a la salud
a un precio que puedan pagar.
Y creo que el mercado nos puede ayudar a decifrar cómo lograr eso,
pero tiene que haber tambien una parte caritativa
o si no, no creo que vamos a crear el tipo de sociedad en que queremos vivir.
Así que, fueron realmente esas lecciones las que me hicieron decidir
crear Acumen Fund hace más o menos seis años.
Es un fondo de capital de riesgo sin fines de lucro para los pobres,
unos cuantos oximorones dentro de una oración.
Esencialmente, levanta fondos caritativos de individuos, funadciones y corporaciones
y después nos volteamos e invertimos capital y préstamos
en entidades ambos con y sin fines de lucro
que entregan salud, vivienda, energía y agua limpia a un costo que puedan pagar
a gente de escasos recursos en Asia del Sur y África,
para que así puedan tomar sus propias deciciones.
Hemos invertido alrededor de 20 millones de dólares en 20 empresas diferentes
y, al hacerlo, hemos creado casi 20,000 empleos
y proveído decenas de millones de servicios a personas
que de otra manera no podrían pagarlos.
Quiero contarles dos historias, ambos ocurrieron en África.
Ambos tienen que ver con invertir en empresarios
que están comprometidos a servir y que realmente conocen sus mercados.
Ambos viven en la confluencia entre la salud pública y la empresa privada
y ambos, porque son fabricantes,
crean empleos directamente, e ingresos indirectamente,
porque trabajan en el sector del paludismo
y África pierde alrededor de 13 billones de dólares al año a causa del paludismo.
Y así, mientras la gente se vuelve más saludable, también se vuelven más ricos.
El primero se llama Advanced Bio-Extracts Limited.
Es una compañía creada en Kenya hace más o menos siete años
por un empresario increíble llamado Patrick Henfrey y sus tres colegas.
Son agricultores veteranos
que han pasado por todos los sube-y-bajas de la agricultura
en Kenya en los últimos 30 años.
Ahora, la planta es una artemisa,
es el componente básico de la artemisinina,
que es el tratamiento mejor conocido para el paludismo.
Es indígena de la China y el Extremo Oriente,
pero dado a que la prevalencia de paludismo es aquí en África,
Patrick y sus colegas dijeron, "Vamos a traerla aquí,
porque es un producto de alto valor agregado."
Los agricultores se ganan entre tres y cuatro veces lo que ganarían con el maíz.
Y así, utilizando el capital paciente, dinero que pudieron levantar temprano en la empresa,
que en realidad devolvió por debajo del mercado general
y que estuvo dispuesto a mantenerse a largo plazo y a combinarse
con asistencia gerencial y estratégica,
ahora han creado una compañía donde le compran a 7,500 agricultores.
Así que eso son 50,000 personas afectadas.
Y creo que algunos de ustedes han visitado --
a estos agricultores los ayudan KickStart y TechnoServe
a ser más autosuficientes.
Ellos la compran, la secan y la traen a esta fábrica
que se compró en parte gracias a capital paciente puesto por Novartis,
que tiene un interés verdadero en conseguir el polvo
para poder hacer Coartem.
Acumen ha estado trabajando con ABE por un año, año y medio,
mirando ambos un modelo nuevo de negocio
y también cómo se vería la expansión para la compañía, ayudando con apoyo gerencial
y a hacer hojas de término y levantar capital.
Y yo de veras llegue a comprender lo que significa capital paciente, de una perspectiva emocional,
en el último mes. Porque la compañía literalmente
estaba a 10 días de comprobar que el producto que ellos producían
tenía la calidad necesaria para hacer Coartem
cuando se encontraron en la crisis de efectivo más grande de su historia.
Y llamamos a todos los inversionistas sociales que conocíamos.
Ahora, algunos de estos inversionistas sociales están muy interesados en África
y entienden la importancia de la agricultura
y hasta ayudaron a los agricultores.
Y aveces, hasta cuando explicamos que si ABE se perdía
todos esos 7,500 empleos se pierden también,
a veces hay una bifurcación entre lo empresarial y lo social.
Y realmente ya es tiempo de que empecemos a pensar de manera más creativa sobre cómo podemos fundir ambas diciplinas.
Así que Acumen hizo no uno, sino dos préstamos puente
y las buenas noticias son que ellos sí lograron alcanzar la clasificación de calidad mundial y ahora están
en las etapas finales de cerrar una ronda de 20 millones para llevar la empresa al póximo nivel,
y me parece que esta va a ser de las compañías más importantes en la África del Este.
Este es Samuel. Es un agricultor.
El vivía en los tugurios de Kibera
cuando su padre lo llamo y le contó sobre la artemisa y el potencial de valor agregado.
Así que se mudo de vuelta a la finca y, para acortar el cuento,
ahora tienen siete acres bajo cultivo.
Los hijos de Samuel están en escuela privada
y él está empezando a ayudar a otros agricultores del área a envolverse en la producción de artemisa --
la dignidad siendo para él más importante que las riquezas.
El próximo ya muchos de ustedes lo conocen.
Hablé de este ejemplo un poco en Oxford, hace dos años
y algunos de ustedes visitaron a A to Z Manufacturing
que es una de las grandes compañías verdaderas en la África del Este.
Es otra que vive en la confluencia entre la salud pública y la empresa privada.
Y esta realmente es una historia de una solución público-privada
que ha funcionado realmente.
Comenzó en Japón. Sumitomo había desarrollado una tecnología
esencialmente para impregnar con insecticida orgánico a una fibra con base de polietileno,
para poder crear una malla cubrecama,
una malla cubrecama contra el paludismo que duraría al menos cinco años sin tener que ser sumergida nuevamente.
Podría alterar el vector, pero al igual que la artemisa,
sólo se había producido en Asia Oriental, y como parte de su responsabilidad social
Sumitomo dijo, "Por qué no experimentamos
a ver si podemos producirla en África, para los africanos?"
UNICEF se ofreció, "Nosotros compramos la majoría de las mallas
y luego las regalamos como parte del compromiso por parte del fondo global
y las Naciones Unidas hacia las mujeres embarazadas y los niños."
Acumen entró con el capital paciente
y ayudamos a identificar al empresario
con quien nos asociaríamos aquí en África
y Exxon proveyó la resina inicial.
Bueno, en la búsqueda de empresarios,
no había ninguno mejor en el mundo que Anuj Shah,
en A to Z Manufacturing Company.
Es una compañía de 40 años, y entiende la fabricación.
Ha pasado de la Tanzanía socialista a la Tanzanía capitalista
y continúa creciendo. Tenía aproximadamente 1,000 empleados cuando la descubrimos.
Y entonces, Anuj tomó el riesgo empresarial aquí en África
de producir un bien que fue comprado por el establecimiento de asistencia international
para trabajar contra el paludismo.
Y, para acortar una historia larga, otra vez, han sido muy exitosos.
En nuestro primer año, la primera red se vendió en octubre de 2003.
En ese entonces pensamos que lo máximo sería distribuir 150,000 redes al año.
Y este año estan produciendo ocho millones de redes al año,
y emplean a 5,000 personas, 90 por ciento de las cuales son mujeres, muy probablemente sin otras destrezas.
Entraron en una empresa conjunta con Sumitomo.
Y, de la perspectiva empresarial para África,
y de la perspectiva de salud pública, estos son logros verdaderos.
Pero es sólo la mitad de la historia si queremos resolver los problemas de la pobreza
porque a largo plazo, no es sostenible.
Es una compañía con un comprador enorme.
Y si cae la gripe aviaria, o por cualquier otra razón
el mundo decide que el paludismo ya no es la prioridad principal, todos perdemos.
Por eso, Anuj y Acumen
han estado hablando de probar las redes en el sector privado
porque la asunción que ha hecho el establecimiento de asistencia internacional es que,
"mira, en un país como Tanzanía
80 por ciento de la población gana menos de dos dólares al día.
Al punto de fabricación, cuesta seis dólares producir estas redes
y le cuesta al establecimiento otros seis distribuirlas,
así que el precio en un mercado libre sería alrededor de 12 dólares por red.
La mayoría de la gente no puede pagar esa cantidad, así que vamos a regalarlas."
Y nosotros dijimos, "Bueno, hay otra opción.
Vamos a usar el mercado como el mejor mecanismo que tenemos para escuchar
y entender a qué precio es que la gente las compraría, para darles la dignidad de poder escoger.
Podemos comenzar a desarrollar un sistema de distribución a nivel local
y, en efecto, podría costarles al público mucho menos."
Así que entramos otra vez con una segunda ronda de capital paciente para A to Z,
un préstamo y también una beca, para que A to Z pudiera jugar con los precios
y escuchar al mercado; y encontraron varias cosas.
Una, que la gente pagaría precios distintos,
pero la gran mayoría de la gente se interesaba en las redes cuando el precio estaba a un dólar por red,
y a ese punto tomaban la decisión de comprarlas.
Y cuando los escuchas, también van a tener mucho que decir
sobre lo que les gusta y lo que no les gusta,
y que algunos de los canales que pensamos que iban a funcionar, no funcionaron.
Pero por la experimentacón e iteración que se pudo lograr
gracias al capital paciente
ahora sabemos que cuesta alrededor de un dólar en el sector privado
para distribuir y un dólar para comprar la red.
Entonces, del punto de vista de política, cuando se empieza con el mercado
tenemos una opción.
Podemos continuar con el modelo que cuesta 12 dólares por red, y el cliente paga zero,
o podemos al menos experimentar con partes del proceso para cobrar un dólar por red,
que le cueste otros seis al sector público por red,
darles la dignidad de elegir a la gente, y tener un sistema de distribución
que, con el tiempo, puede llegar a sostenerse por sí mismo.
Hay que empezar a tener conversaciones como esta
y no creo que haya mejor manera de comenzar que usando el mercado,
pero también trayendo a otra gente a la mesa alrededor de esta idea.
Siempre que voy a visitar a A to Z, pienso en mi abuela, Stella.
Ella era muy parecida a esas mujeres sentadas detrás de las máquinas de coser.
Ella creció en una finca en Austria, muy pobre,
sin mucha educación.
Se mudó a los Estados Unidos donde conoció a mi abuelo,
que era transportador de cemento,
y tuvieron nueve hijos. Tres de ellos murieron de bebés.
Mi abuela tenía tuberculosis y trabajaba en una fábrica de costura,
haciendo camisas y ganando alrededor de 10 centavos por hora.
Ella, como muchas de las mujeres que veo en A to Z,
trabajaba fuerte todos los días, entendía lo que era sufrir,
tenía una fe profunda en Dios, amaba a sus hijos
y nunca hubiera aceptado una limosna.
Pero como tenía la oportunidad del mercado
y vivía en una sociedad que le proveía la seguridad
de tener acceso a servicios de salud y educación a un precio razonable,
sus hijos y los hijos de ellos pudieron vivir
vidas con propósito verdadero y seguir sus sueños.
Miro a mis hermanos y a mis primos -- y como dije,
somos muchos --
y veo maestros y músicos, encargados de fondos de cobertura, diseñadores.
Una hermana que hace realidad los sueños de otros.
Y mi deseo, cunado veo a esas mujeres, cuando conozco a esos agricultores,
y pienso en toda la gente que habita este continente,
que trabajan fuerte todos los días,
es que tengan ese sentido de oportunidad y posibilidad
y que también puedan creer y tener acceso a los servicios necesarios
para que sus hijos también puedan vivir vidas de gran propósito.
No debería ser tan difícil.
Pero lo que requiere es un compromiso por parte de todos nosotros
a rechazar las asunciones triviales,
a salirnos de nuestras cajas ideológicas.
Requiere invertir en esos empresarios que están comprometidos
tanto al servicio como al éxito.
Requiere abrir los brazos, ambos, muy amplios
y esperar muy poco amor a cambio,
pero demandar responsabilidad en la rendición de cuentas
y traer esa misma responsabilidad en la rendición de cuentas a la mesa también.
Y por encima de todo, por encima de todo,
requiere que todos tengamos el coraje y la paciencia,
ya seamos ricos o pobres, africanos o no-africanos,
locales o de la diaspora, izquierdistas o derechistas,
para empezar a escucharnos los unos a los otros de verdad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)